[Music]
well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look then at what is on
the front pages time to see what's
making the headlines and there's
certainly plenty to talk about uh with
the observer's chief leader writer sonia
soda and the political commentator salma
shah with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the front pages let us crack on with
those the financial times leading with
testimony from the january the sixth
insurrection committee in washington
where it was today alleged that former
president donald trump attempted to join
the armed mob storming the capital even
going so far as trying to grab the
steering wheel of his limousine
the eye has word of first minister
nicholas sturgeon's announcement that
the scottish government intends to hold
a second independence referendum in
october next year
that is also the lead story for the
guardian as you can see
we're reporting on the sentencing in the
maxwell case the metro has the headline
gillane caged for 20 years
and the telegraph here's the boris
johnson is involved in an ongoing
disagreement with the defense secretary
and the head of the army who want to
increase military spending
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let us bring in our guest
then sunny soda and salma shah and
welcome to both of you well here we are
then let's start with the i salmer shall
we uh sturgeon's new bid to split from
the uk announcing a plan but um
realistically how far will she get with
it
well there are a lot of caveats to this
plan because clearly westminster is not
granting her um a new referendum so she
is saying that she will
go for one on october 19th next year and
that she is going to ask the lord africa
which is the chief legal officer in the
scottish government to um negotiate the
legality of this in the uk court so she
is trying to find a way to make this
referendum stick as it were and make it
legal and make it um
workable so that it actually becomes a
reality i think there's going to be a
lot of chewing and throwing about this
um certainly westminster is going to try
and hold it back but she's also said
that she's going to make the next uh
election um
a single issue election about
independence in order to try and gain
that mandate to do it so it is not clean
cut and it looks like it's going to be
messy for a long time yet and in
fighting the next general election on
one issue
um you know is there is through a danger
that actually helps the conservative
party certainly does it wipe labor off
uh do you think sonia
well i think when you take a step back
from this um you have to ask why would
you try and and now try and have a
referendum on scottish independence next
year given that the last time was only
eight years ago
if you look at scottish opinion polls
things haven't changed very much polls
um continue to show a majority for
staying in the uk
and if you look at polling on whether
voters want a referendum next year in
scotland fewer than a third of voters
scottish voters think a referendum is a
good idea and there's a lot of snp
voters for whom it's not a priority
that's shown in the polls so you've got
to ask the question why is nicholas
sturgeon doing this and i think it is
because she wants to distract actually
from you know the snp have been in
government in scotland for a long time
like any government who's been in in you
know government a long time uh there are
voters who've fallen away from them um
some of the snp's domestic record is
really quite patchy so obviously she
wants uh the next selection to be about
scottish independence the smb's raison
zetra because the snp don't want to be
held to account for some of the domestic
failings that voters up in scotland are
starting to notice so i think this
actually is very cynical uh by nicholas
sturgeon you know in the big picture in
the grand scale of things i'm in favor
of self-determination but there's no
evidence to suggest the scottish people
want a referendum next year it feels
like quite a cynical ploy by the snp
and the snp um also selma suggesting
that obviously the aim would be to
rejoin the european union the single
market and so on and they will be
publishing plans soon about what to do
about that hard border between scotland
and england
very complicated we guess but would
northern ireland's experience do you
think affect voting on the issue if
there was ever to be a referendum
well potentially it will affect uh
voting on the issue of course northern
irish and
northern ireland situation is unique
because of course there is the good
friday agreement to consider and it is a
lot more about um
the history of northern ireland what i
think is more interesting about the eu
dimension is whether the eu would be
welcoming scotland with open arms given
that there are so many issues around
europe not least in spain with bath
separatists um thinking about how
actually other countries might try and
apply to the eu to be able to have some
kind of credibility when they break away
from where they are currently so there
is there are a lot of dynamics um at
play here and uh it's not necessary that
the eu would consider scotland as for
membership straight off the bat
well certainly nicholas sturgeon is
pictured on the front page of the
financial times but their lead story is
this surprise testimony we've had some
extraordinary testimony and what we
learned about donald trump's behavior
and reaction as the capital riots
unfolded sonia that he wanted he says to
join his people
i mean it's just sort of jaw-dropping
the stuff that we're we're learning
through these congressional hearings and
today the revelation is is that trump
wanted to go out there wanted to join uh
these protesters who descended on the
capital broke through security with
weapons you know with threatening people
in the capitol building and he wanted to
go and join them and you know he was
told that he
he couldn't um by his security and then
he sort of tried to grab the steering
wheel and even um you know put his hands
around the neck of the person who told
him that he can do it i mean it's just
um
really kind of quite extraordinary stuff
this is a former president of the united
states that we're talking about um uh so
i mean who would have thought that we
would have been here um it is just
extraordinary it's kind of hard to sort
of find the adequate words to describe
it but we're also learning a lot about
not just what happened today but the you
know what was going on behind the scenes
you know what trump was doing to sort of
try and prevent the smooth transition of
the president presidency the election
that he lost uh to to president uh biden
so
i mean it's just unbelievable that in
one of the largest democracies of the
world this is what it came to and this
is cassidy hutchinson the young aide to
mark meadows uh the right-hand man of
donald trump selma and the quotes are
really extraordinary um she went on to
say that trump had said of his armed
supporters they're not here to hurt me
take their swear word take the mags away
meaning the metal detectors that have
been placed to secure the capital let my
people in
they can march to the capitol from here
that he agreed with the comments they
had said about mike pence who'd been
trying to ruin the election result and
so on does any of this have any impact
though on donald trump supporters and
the likelihood of him running again
well this is the huge question isn't it
because you know all these congressional
hearings actually going to end up in um
ensuring that donald trump is no longer
able legally to be able to uh be on the
ticket or run as president again
so we know that his supporters are die
hard we know that they are still we
still believe in trump and that trump is
definitely trying to keep that flame
alive for his next potential run
and i think there is going to be a lot
of pressure on these congressional
hearings to try and be definitive about
this and i think the republican party
is waiting to see what's going to happen
here because the trump endorsement in a
lot of quarters in the republican party
still matters and that is a very scary
thing when you read the details um from
from this testimony i mean he he
clearly
was in a position
of transferring power from himself as
president on to the next president and
was essentially
allowing people that he probably knew
had weapons to march on the capital and
refer to them as his people this is very
tribalistic it is very scary and i think
the fact that a lot of people are still
waiting to see whether this potentially
leads to him still getting on a
presidential ticket for the republican
party is actually quite frightening
yes indeed some might say it should
it should lead to criminal action but
there we are um let's leave let's go to
the metro now uh shall we sonia this is
the news that gillian maxwell has been
jailed for 20 years fined as well a five
year supervision on top of that it takes
her to uh to 80 and beyond with all of
that i guess and an apology from her in
court today to those who were there
about her association with jeffrey
epstein this disgraced financier rather
than specifically her actions in this
yeah it was it was it was an apology
that wasn't really an apology i think if
you read the words and considering the
trauma and the suffering she inflicted
on those women who were children at the
time i mean this is she was convicted of
sex trafficking and you know
participating in the sexual assault of
children um you know those are those
words just don't come close to um to
sort of you know taking responsibility
for the evil that was inflicted on those
on those girls on those young women so
um you know it's it's a long sentence i
expect some people will think that it
should potentially be even longer but i
think the question is is is where where
is he it's absolutely right that she
faces accountability for her the
appalling role she played in the sex
trafficking and rape of these of these
young women but you know and no men have
been held accountable it was obviously
jeffrey epstein who's now dead um but we
know that these girls were trafficked
not just for epstein but for other um
other rich powerful men
and somehow they have not faced uh
consequences they've not faced
accountability for their actions and i
just don't know how that can be allowed
to stand by prosecutors sonia salmer
there is so much to talk about we will
move on take a quick break come back
with the news that after a series of
failings the met police has been put
into special measures
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now sonia soda and
sal michelle welcome back to both of you
um so let's go to the times uh sonia one
thing has led to another and now the
uk's biggest police force is in special
measures but indeed the um the
organization who's brought this um talks
about systemic problems now um including
all those scandals so what what do you
make of the news tonight
well i think this is hardly going to
come as a surprise to people who've been
following stories about the performance
of the met in the last sort of 12 to 24
months and it's a long time coming
and it sounds like the report is going
to make extremely um concerning uh
reading so it references
all of the terrible failings that have
come to light um in the last year or two
in the you know institutional misogyny
um institutional uh racism uh you know
the treatment uh the the strip search of
um a black child child q completely
innocent in her school the massive
failures of the investigation um into
the murders committed by stephen port so
that's you know evidence of
institutional homophobia the sexist and
misogynist messages between uh charring
cross police officers the list just goes
on and what else is emerging is that the
inspector also looked at kind of key
performance indicators and found that
the mec were performing well below
national standards on things like
answering and handling 999 calls um huge
numbers of crimes going investigated 69
000
so it all adds up i think to an
incredibly damning picture that won't be
a surprise to uh lots of people and i
think you know in many ways the question
is how has it taken so long for this to
happen and for the inspectorate to go in
and and and have a look at things but
it's it's very good that it's been done
but you know
big questions about the extent to which
new leadership in the met will be able
to get a grip of this yes matt parr the
watchdogs inspector for london said the
abduction rape and murder of sarah
everard by a serving officer of course
we remember had a chilling effect on
public trust and confidence but it was a
recent force-wide inspection which
prompted the move to special measures uh
past cited 14 new failures including a
barely adequate standard of crime
recording accuracy so lots for them to
look into um sam i just want to finish
with the with the pictures that are all
over the newspapers of the extraordinary
woman who was damn debra james who was
very sadly the announcement from her
family has died
yeah absolutely tragic news and yet
we knew that this day was going to come
and come soon because deborah has
campaigned about it talked about it
and yet somehow it just still seems
quite surreal um
that she's not there because even
towards the end just full of full of so
much life and campaigning to the end
about her condition of bowel cancer and
making sure that people understood
what was uh what how they needed to
check themselves and and the the
the extremeness of the illness that
takes you so
just incredibly sad news very sad for
her family but um what an amazing legacy
even though
her age of 40 years is nothing at all